voilà c'est l'heure de notre second
débat vous le savez on essaie le plus
souvent possible de le choisir
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour on prend du du recul quand c'est
possible et je vous propose un gros plan
sur la situation à Mayotte le sang une
énième département français secoué
depuis des mois par des violences que
certains lits directement à
l'immigration clandestine venue de Lille
voisine des Comores après deux visites
du ministre de l'Intérieur en à peine 4
mois quelle est la situation sur place
nos reporters Jérôme Rabier et Clément
Debès se sont rendus dans cet archipel
de l'océan Indien regardez
c'est un nouveau cran dont la violence
qui ravage Mayotte les bus scolaires
sont désormais la cible des délinquants
comme sur ces images de novembre dernier
des jeunes armés de machettes n'hésitent
pas à s'en prendre à des écoliers pour
leur dérober leurs effets personnels
[Musique]
une violence aveugle qui plonge le
département français dans la terreur
quelques semaines après l'attaque du bus
leur est au bilan pour la société
Matisse qui gère la moitié du transport
scolaire de Lille alors ça c'est notre
bûche du 16 novembre dernier qui s'est
fait totalement pulvériser par une
attaque de nigelle des vitres cassées à
coups de pierre à coup de couteau qu'on
appelle le chombo ici donc aucune vitre
n'a tenu j'ai perdu 80% du vitrage de ce
véhicule
pas un jour ne passe sans qu'un incident
ne surviennent pour cette entreprise
mettant en péril l'activité économique
les droits de retrait nous ont coûté à
l'échelle du groupement près d'un demi
million d'euros c'est-à-dire que nous
sommes rémunérés au kilomètre quand nous
ne roulons pas parce que nos conducteurs
ont peur de prendre le service nous ne
sommes pas rémunérés en face de ça on
rajoute 200000 pour réparer nos bus
caille assez donc on est déjà 700 000
euros de dépenses qui n'est pas prévu
pour un groupe de transporteurs ça
devient intenable à l'origine de ces
attaques des jeunes mineurs isolés
étrangers qui vivent dans les bidons
villes de l'île les sombres dans la
délinquance ils sont majoritairement nés
de parents arrivés des Comores voisines
de façon clandestine et qui tente la
périlleuse traversée d'à peine 60 km qui
sépare l'île d'Anjouan aux Comores des
côtes mahoraises dans l'espoir d'un
avenir meilleur
à Mayotte élue comme habitants lit
directement immigration et délinquance
et la principale réponse de l'État et
migratoire au centre de rétention de
Mayotte on a la plus forte activité de
France le centre de rétention accueille
en moyenne plus de 30 000 si par an sur
la moyenne de l'ensemble des CRA de
France globalement sur l'année 2021 on a
accueilli nous avons accueilli 63% de
l'ensemble des rétentions en France
il fait les deux
ici les clandestins ne passent que
quelques heures dans le centre et sont
expulsés en moins de 24 heures
et comme ce jour-là chaque matin environ
70 Comoriens sont raccompagnés sur les
quais d'où partent les ferry
c'est un bateau commercial sur lequel on
embarque les retenues et qui seront qui
seront renvoyés aux Comores sur un même
sur un même bateau qu'avec des passagers
en fait commerciaux et on fait
d'éloignement en métropole par bateau ou
par avion mais on met jamais 100 ou 150
personnes éloignées en même temps sur un
bateau quoi non et qu'ici qu'on voit ça
tout à fait
combien d'entre eux retenteront leur
chance impossible à savoir une seule
certitude Mayotte subit une pression
démographique unique en France sur les
300 000 habitants officiels de Lille la
moitié sont des étrangers et sur les
plus de 10 000 naissances annuelles à la
maternité de mahmoudzou plus des trois
quarts sont issus de parents étrangers
Mayotte au bord de l'explosion c'est le
titre de ce reportage de Jérôme Rabier
Clément de Hesse vous pourrez d'ailleurs
découvrir la la version longue de ce de
ce reportage samedi à 18h sur notre
antenne c'est aussi le thème de notre
débat évidemment avec Elise palomarez
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
socio-anthropologue enseignants de
chercheurs à l'Université de Rouen
Tally Mohamed swahili bonsoir bienvenue
à vous vous êtes sénateur RDPI de
Mayotte membre de la délégation
sénatoriale aux outre-mer Françoise
Vergès bonsoir politologue bienvenue à
vous Mathieu croissanto éditoris
politiques et restez à mes côtés et puis
j'accueille également en duplex Anne
perzolafon qui rédactrice en chef au
journal de de Mayotte bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je vais
commencer avec vous rapidement pour
pouvoir revenir sur la scène qui date de
novembre je le rappelle qu'on a vu en au
début de ce reportage un bus scolaire
attaqué à la machette est-ce que
cette exceptionnel malheureusement
habituelle comment vous analysez ce qui
ce type de d'image
d'abord c'est non c'est habituel Thomas
Bailly de William Bailly Bardon de
Transdev la bien dit en fait les bus
scolaires se font régulièrement
caillasser mais contrairement à ce qui
était dit dans votre reportage ce ne
sont pas que le fait en fait il y a pas
des scolaires et des jeunes en bande et
en situation irrégulière qui sont à
l'extérieur qui attaquent ces bus en
fait il y a déjà une qui sont à
l'intérieur de ce bus même qui renseigne
d'autres bandes de jeunes en disant
voilà un tel dont on voulait se venger
il est dans le bus donc vous pouvez
attaquer le bus donc en fait la
situation elle est moins nette qu'il n'y
paraît et c'est ce qui complexifie tout
le débat en fait c'est
le débat je parle du débat de lien entre
l'immigration et la délinquance voilà
donc en fait ce lien existe mais vous
parliez de lien direct pour moi il est
indirect on pourra approfondir
évidemment longuement dans dans dans ce
débat tu as dit Mohamed faylie que vous
dites les les Maori comment ces
violences au quotidien ça fait combien
de temps et à quel point ça pardon c'est
un peu trivial mais ça pourrit leur vie
quoi c'est un enfer que vit les mains au
quotidien
c'est violence n'ont pas toujours été
aussi intense et
aussi prolongée depuis
4-5 ans avec un pic à partir de la crise
covid ou les gens étaient dans la
situation que nous connaissons
et
aujourd'hui au quotidien même si on
assiste à un petit peu d'académie et
bien c'est c'est violence continuent à
pourrir la vie de majoriser des démarrer
ils disent palomarès alors quand on
parle de bande de jeunes c'est tellement
vague que bon on peut tout mettre
derrière ce terme voilà est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en dites est-ce
qu'elles sont nombreuses organisées
qu'il est qui qu'il est qui en sont les
membres en quelque sorte
quand on parle de viol
ent avoir de quoi on parle parce que
même c'est ces bandes de jeunes ne sont
pas la l'unique forme qu'on peut trouver
donc c'est quelque chose d'important de
distinguer entre ce qu'on peut
identifier comme de la petite
délinquance de survie et l'Insee l'a
bien montré des voiles à l'arrachée
téléphone voilà beaucoup de vols
d'appropriation qui ont la particularité
d'être commis avec violence donc c'est
une particulièrement visible et
effectivement c'est très ça affecte le
quotidien
pour ce qui est des vols et des
violences commises en bande qui sont
beaucoup plus graves on a affaire à des
phénomènes assez classiques assez connus
d'inscription territoriale qui concerne
la des jeunes à perdre la fin on a déjà
dit de toutes origines en fait il ne
s'agit absolument pas on le peut
l'observer depuis le tribunal les mises
en cause ne sont pas des mineurs
étrangers isolés ce ne sont pas eux
qu'on retrouve dans les bandes et là ce
ne sont pas que eux non ce ne sont même
pas ce ne sont pas forcément
vraiment il y a justement d'autant toute
cette dimension de de socialisation dans
la bande d'appartenance à la bande on
retrouve davantage en fait de la
vulnérabilité sociale des familles de la
déscolure déscolarisation qui va
concerner des jeunes immigrés mais pas
que et surtout on retrouve dans les
causes les défaillances des institutions
et en fait c'est phénomène c'est quand
même bien identifié par les sociologues
c'est si la bande prend le pas sur tout
le reste c'est bien souvent parce que
c'est tout ce qui reste d'accord on va
détailler tout ça et évidemment
Françoise Vergès je le disais en
lancement le ministre de l'Intérieur il
s'est rendu deux fois maillot de fin
août fin décembre est-ce que quand on
est on va évidemment brosser le portrait
le plus large possible on a on a une
quarantaine de minutes mais est-ce que
la réponse sécuritaire elle est elle est
incontournable est-ce qu'il faut d'abord
en passer par là
la réponse sécuritaire est toujours une
réponse à court terme elle ne va pas
résoudre à long terme les questions sur
le sénateur disait que ça se pose depuis
le plus longtemps et évidemment les
images qu'on voit sont choquantes mais
quand elles sont faites pour ça mais moi
j'aurais aimé entendre des jeunes par
exemple ces jeunes dont on parle et on
parle d'eux mais on les entend pas moi
je voudrais savoir qu'est-ce qu'elles
sont leurs qu'est-ce qui se passe vous
voyez c'est-à-dire pour répondre à ce
qui se passe il faut quand même partir à
partir des personnes des premières
concernées qui sont ces gens moi la
réponse est aussi des Mahorais qui qui
subissent les violences évidemment donc
la réponse sécurité il faut bien qu'elle
interdienne
on entend aucune de ces personnes on
parle pour eux on parle pour elle alors
là il y a une chose et puis la réponse
sécuritaire on l'a vu c'est pas la
première fois c'est pas le premier
territoire où ça se passe la réponse
sécurité à des problèmes et jusqu'à
présent aucune de ces réponses
sécuritaires n'a permet de réels
résultats dans quelques pays que ce soit
les
si les gens veulent l'immigrer les gens
émigrés ça fait simplement plus de morts
ça fait simplement plus de misère ça
fait simplement plus de pauvreté et plus
de policiers c'est une demande des
habitants de de Mayotte quand même plus
de police plus plus de répression face à
ces violences la réponse sécurité et la
réponse immédiatement requise par la
population vous savez vous pouvez parler
de prévention vous pouvez parler de de
beaucoup de choses
à dessin mais la personne qui est chez
elle qui n'a rien demandé à personne et
qui se fait agresser gratuitement
ces discours sont inattendables pour
pour cette personne là et la
responsabilité c'est celle qui est
demandé tout de suite et il faut cette
réponse sécuritaire ensuite je suis
d'accord que il y a aussi un côté
préventif
à travailler ce côté préventif
malheureusement pendant des années
localement on n'y a pas assez travaillé
tout simplement parce que ce n'est pas
dans la culture locale un enfant qui
pose problème un enfant qui est éduqué
et qui reçoit des réponses dans la
famille dans le village et ça ne coulait
pas de source que pour des enfants qui
posent des problèmes il faille il
fallait une réponse institutionnelle et
c'est de là d'où vient le le malentendu
c'est à dire que là où il devait avoir
de la prévention depuis des années et
bien cette prévention n'a pas eu lieu ou
n'a pas eu lieu assez et malheureusement
beaucoup de ces enfants qui ne sont plus
des enfants ont grandi et aujourd'hui
répondre de cette façon dans la société
donc le maori qui n'a jamais vécu ces
scènes de violence la réponse immédiate
qu'il demande c'est la réponse
sécuritaire est-ce que est-ce que c'est
violence menacent la sécurité la société
tout entière c'est ce que dit la
sénatrice LR du Val d'Oise qui est
membre de la délégation sénatoriale aux
outre-mer au Sénat Jacqueline Eustache
Bruno c'était le 7 décembre dernier
écoutez
armée de machettes coucou ou simplement
de tesson de bouteille
des climats de terreur dans le sangeme
département français bande violence
alcool main coupée guerre de gang
caillassage de voiture de police la
liste est longue de tous les fléaux que
subissent les maorets depuis longtemps
livré à eux-mêmes des milliers de jeunes
mineurs isolés sans papiers peuple des
bidonvilles à Mayotte sans avenir ces
jeunes hors-la-loi n'ont rien à perdre
et menace la société tout entière cette
phrase moi qui m'a marqué Françoise
Vergès et jeune menace la société tout
entière je trouve quand même de parler
d'enfants de jeunes de cette manière on
dirait je sais pas c'est très
déshumanisé on a l'impression de
barbares à qui on peut pas parler qui
menace la société tout entière mais ce
sont des enfants je veux dire revenons à
la réalité et qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
je veux dire qu'est-ce que je veux dire
on va quoi on va aller tous les mettre
en prison ça va être ça la solution je
veux dire cet assistance comme ça sur
ces mots attaque violence les personnes
mais je veux dire il y a beaucoup dit
répondons évidemment en mettant plus de
police plus de barbelés faisons de
Mayotte une île prison d'une certaine
manière sur lesquels seulement les
Mahorais mahoraise de droit peuvent
aller faisons une île prison je veux
dire ça c'est toujours une solution bien
sûr si on prend les choses comme cela et
qu'on voit ces personnes comme étant
simplement dangereux simplement
dangereuses mais ces personnes il y en a
qui travaillent il y a énormément aussi
de travailler légal à Mayotte et c'est
ces personnes qui remplissent ces
métiers dans le bâtiment dans la
restauration comme employer de maison
donc il y a aussi toute cette partie on
a l'impression que si vous voulez y
aller maorilles peuples peuple très
raisonnable je veux dire répondant à la
loi et puis une espèce de masse barbare
qui serait dangereuse
et de pas simplifier dans ce débat
évidemment je voyais Anne perzo à fond
qui voulait intervenir peut-être
justement sur
c'est violent dont on parlait ou
l'intervention de la sénatrice à
l'instant c'était là-dessus vous les
réagir merci Thomas sur un peu sur tout
parce que en fait on est en train de
mélanger beaucoup de choses en fait d'un
côté quand vous entendez quand vous avez
des amis qui circulent le soir qui vont
au cinéma etc et qui reviennent qui
disent qu'ils ont qui envoie des SMS
dans des groupes WhatsApp attention
caillassage à tel endroit à tel endroit
on a l'habitude maintenant mais on est
tous un peu des baroudeurs nous qui
sommes à Mayotte ça fait quand même
Mayotte on est baroudeur ce n'est pas
normal est-ce que vous dans votre
entourage je parlais à la politologue et
à tout le monde sur le plateau est-ce
que vous dans votre entourage quand il
vous allait sortir ce soir il va y avoir
quelqu'un qui va vous dire je me suis
fait caillasser etc non pourquoi en fait
ce qui se passe c'est que c'est que
lorsqu'il y a des expulsions d'adultes
quand il y a des expulsions il ne
signale pas qu'il y a des enfants donc
on le sait ces enfants restent sur le
territoire sont pris en charge par des
autres et des tentes à la manière de ce
que des états ni Mohamed sauf qu'avant
en fait ils étaient dans ces familles
élargies de manière assez sévère enfin
on pouvait sévir il y avait des
châtiments corporels là maintenant on se
retrouve sur dans des familles qui ont
un mode un peu occidental qui ont
eux-mêmes cinq six ou sept enfants qui
ne peuvent pas prendre cet enfant qui
est laissé par ses enfants qui se
retrouvent à la rue et pris dans ce
phénomène de banque elle est là la
logique en fait et que en fait on est
maintenant dans une société
occidentale ou les châtiments corporels
il n'y a plus lieu et en fait il y a une
perte de repères de ses parents et
Mahoré ou étranger qui disent comment on
va les prendre en charge et en fait
l'enfant devient pas un enfant roi mais
c'est un peu ça donc quand vous dites en
fait mais ils sont violents mais c'est
ça reste des enfants oui mais ça reste
des enfants en fait qui ont vécu le
traumatisme de venir en quoi ça de nuit
peut-être qui ont vu un chavirage qui
ont qui sont un peu livrés eux-mêmes
donc en fait ce sont des enfants qui
deviennent adultes avant l'heure c'est
ça qu'il faut qu'il faut voir et et
c'est ce sont ces enfants qui nous
menacent tous le soir quand on sort etc
ils sont en bande qu'elle voulait avec
des machettes et on fait pas les fier
hein et pourtant on est tous je vous dis
à Mayotte un peu baroudeur de de vivre
là et nous en fait on veut on veut que
ses enfants soient bien entourés sont
pris en charge j'en veux pour preuve que
les communes qui font un vrai effort les
CCAS ici sont très récents les centres
communaux d'absence sociale ils sont
très récents il faut d'une part comme le
disait le sénateur tanné il faut la
gendarmerie il faut une présence et on a
vu l'évolution beaucoup moins de
violence depuis que la gendarmerie fait
acte de présence dans les rues en
nocturne et dans la journée il y a
beaucoup moins de de violence donc comme
quoi ça marche et les communes qui
agissent avec leur CCAS on voit vraiment
une évolution positive c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait une prise en charge des
jeunes mais il faut les deux
il faut les deux
Élise Palomares sur ce finalement on est
en train de de confronter de deux
options si on se met à la place du
gouvernement il y a l'option du temps
court qui est peut-être une réponse trop
sécuritaire en tout cas c'est ce que
j'entends dans la bouche peut-être de de
toutes les deux sur ce plateau et puis
il y a une réponse de long terme mais
souvent on se dit il faut la violence
pour que la réponse de long terme
intervienne c'est arrivé par exemple
dans dans certaines cités de banlieue en
France est-ce que c'est ce phénomène
auquel on va peut-être assister à
Mayotte alors sur la réponse de court
terme quand même il y a lieu de
s'interroger pour une des opérations qui
restent des opérations de maintien de
l'ordre face à des bandes de jeunes dont
on a parlé de la logique qui a consisté
à envoyer le raid il y a 12 policiers du
Raid qui ont été déployées là-bas
effectivement qui sont donc face à des
enfants et qui ont un principe
l'autorisation de tirer à balles réel
alors est-ce qu'on est dans la
continuité de type de de
de maintien de l'or qui ont quand même
une triste histoire dans les outre-mer
est-ce que voilà on disait n'a pas
l'autorisation de tuer n'importe qui
n'importe quand en tout cas on peut
s'intéresser sur l'utilisation de ce
type de ce type de force sur le plan je
pense que si on parle des unités d'élite
que ce soit le raid ou le GIGN ce sont
celles qui savent mieux ne pas utiliser
leurs armes et ne les utiliser que
j'étais utilisé bon j'ai dit que on peut
s'interroger sur le fait d'envoyer des
unités de lutte anti-terroriste pour
faire face à des bandes de jeunes qui ne
sont pas spécifiques à Mayotte encore
une fois c'est des phénomènes
moi j'essaye de mettre à la place de ce
bref quand même le témoignage de Dan
perso Laffont il est frappant quoi je
veux sortir et je suis obligé de
d'appeler les amis pour voir où sont les
kayaks les cahiers
[Musique]
je vous donne la parole juste après
allez bonne chose sur le long terme les
réponses qui sont apportées en termes de
restriction
vous disiez si jamais on transformait
l'île en forteresse il ne resterait plus
que les mahorets cela ne ferait pas
disparaître le problème puisque le
problème n'est pas causé par
l'immigration et les délinquants dont on
parle les bandes de jeunes dont on parle
sont composées encore une fois de jeunes
de toutes les origines et cette les
quartiers dont on parle des bidonvilles
dont on parle quatre logements sur 10
sont des habitats en tôle mais ça
concerne aussi un tiers des Français
Mahorais qui vivent dans ces logements
et qui se font éventuellement expulser
dans les opérations de destruction des
bidonvilles ça concerne des
propriétaires français
entre immigration et délinquance une
version et violence est-ce que vous le
faites alors avant d'avenir moi
j'aimerais de demander à à mesdames
d'aller faire un tour à Mayotte et je ne
leur souhaite pas de vivre ce que une
partie de la population vit sur cette
île il y a des jeunes il y a des gens
qui se sont fait tuer il y a des gens se
sont fait mutiler la scène dans le bus
ce n'est pas une scène isolée ce sont
des des phénomènes des actes qui sont
perpétrés au quotidien et c'est vrai que
ce sont des actes si on y répond pas
sont de nature à menacée toute toute la
société la question du lien entre
l'immigration et la violence
vous aimez beaucoup la poser vous voulez
les journalistes
je pense que les habitants l'ont un peu
posé en votant massivement Marine Le Pen
à la dernière
où vous avez
75% des naissances qui sont le fait
d'être d'étrangers où vous avez 45% de
la population 45% des naissances qui
sont le fait d'une mère et d'un père en
situation irrégulière où vous avez les
chiffres vient d'être donnés plus de 60%
des reconduites à la frontière de la
France qui se font à partir de ce
caillou de 300 de 374 km². est-ce que
cette question se pose encore les
mahoriens n'en peuvent plus
aucun territoire n'accepterait la moitié
le 10% de ce que vivent aujourd'hui les
Maori C'est ça la vraie question est-ce
qu'on peut continuer dans un territoire
comme Mayotte à ne pas savoir du jour au
lendemain combien on va construire des
colles combien on va construire
d'hôpitaux combien on va amener de l'eau
pour pour la population c'est ça ce qui
se passe il y a la limite le Mahoré s'en
fiche de savoir qui commet ces crimes et
ses et ses délits le maori y en a marre
et vu que que ça cesse que ça soit des
des jeunes que ça soit des moins jeunes
en situation régulière en situation
irrégulière elle m'aurait a envie de
vivre comme n'importe quel citoyen
français dans la tranquillité et dans la
paix et ce sont c'est ça les questions
ce sont ça les questions qui se posent
alors ce lien immigration et violence il
y a pas que les journalistes qu'ils font
c'est aussi un peu la ligne de du
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérard Darmanin
qui souhaite Mathieu on va faire un
focus là-dessus durcir les règles du
droit du console à Mayotte ça ouvre un
vrai débat pour oui parce que c'est
devenu une habitude presque une marque
de fabrique pour le ministre de
l'Intérieur à chaque fois que Gérald
Darmanin seront à Mayotte ou par le
Mayotte il monstre les muscles il donne
de la voile alors il montre des muscles
avec des forces de l'ordre il donne de
la voix avec un refrain désormais un
refrain pardon désormais bien connu qui
sonne comme une réponse miracle à tout
les problèmes réformons le droit du sol
dans le sens de dans le sang une ième
département français alors ça a été
entonné la première fois par Gérald
Darmanin lors d'un déplacement en août
2021 ça a été de nouveau
réitérer un an plus tard en août 2022 ça
a été de nouveau chanté si j'ose dire
une nouvelle fois l'occasion de la Saint
Sylvestre que ministre de l'Intérieur
avait choisi de passer avec les forces
de l'ordre sur l'archipel c'est donc un
air bien connu mais dont les paroles à
chaque fois s'envolent parce que pour
l'instant rien n'a changé ça devait
figurer en partie dans le projet de loi
collectivité locale de Gérard Darmanin
puis ça n'a pas figuré et puis c'est
encore en suspens que veut-il changer
alors la situation on en a parlé
démographique de de Mayotte et
particulière parce que lui il a vu une
population multipliées en quatre anges
je crois en gros depuis
et que elle compte aujourd'hui près de
400 000 habitants je crois et que en
raison de la forte natalité et
l'immigration provenance des autres îles
de l'archipel des Comores et de
l'Afrique de l'Est elle pourrait
atteindre dit-on 700000 habitants d'ici
25 ans si on ne change rien ça quand je
dis dit-on c'est l'intérieur qui le dit
non l'idée du disposition spécifique
pour Mayotte et il faut rappeler que les
règles de la d'obtention de la
nationalité française ils sont déjà pas
les mêmes que sur la métropole le reste
du territoire depuis la loi asile
émigration 2018 les conditions
d'obtention de la nationalité française
sont plus difficiles il faut qu'au moins
des parents et résider de manière
régulière et ininterrompue pendant les
trois mois qui précèdent la naissance de
l'enfant ce qui n'est pas le cas
ailleurs en France et puis Gérald
Darmanin veut même porter ce délai à un
an ça pose un petit problème d'égalité
on peut l'imaginer en 2018 le disait la
loi Conseil constitutionnel avait validé
en rappelant que la Constitution près
que les lois peuvent faire l'objet
d'adaptation tenant au caractéristiques
et contraintes particulières des
collectivités d'outre-mer et que dans ce
cas la disposition était justifiée
contenue de la pression migratoire
particulière qui exercent qui s'exerce
sur Mayotte et si le Conseil
constitutionnel changeait la vie sur
cette nouvelle disposition Gérald
Darmanin explique désormais que le
Président de la République de la
République serait prêt à l'introduire en
tout cas qui pourrait prochainement en
parler lors de sa prochaine réforme
institutionnelle merci Mathieu je
rappelle le droit du sol un enfant né en
France de parents étranger peu à sa
majorité devenir français s'il habitait
en France pendant plusieurs années avant
ses 18 ans l'exception Mayotte c'est il
doit aussi prouver que l'un de ses
parents au moins résidé en France
légalement vous ne l'avez dit depuis 3
mois au moment de sa naissance Françoise
Vergès
se durcissement du droit du sol pourquoi
est-il inquiétant
est-ce que c'est très symbolique c'est
quand même très très symbolique il est
vrai que le droit du sol n'a jamais été
totalement que cela en France que la
seule loi mais elle a fait de la France
quelque chose pour le reste du monde
pour les exiler les réfugiés qui se
disaient si je vais là-bas mes enfants
n'étaient un énorme ça a été énorme je
veux dire encore aujourd'hui cette idée
que vous êtes de vous donner français
non pas parce que le droit du sang parce
que quand même la question des parents
c'est droit du sang contre droit du sol
et droit du sang ça fait quand même fait
aussi ça donne des échos parfois assez
inquiétants donc là en deux en remettant
en cause le droit du sol et sans revenir
à l'histoire tout ça ça remet en cause
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui dans le
monde dans lequel nous vivons 21e siècle
et très fort sous la forme de défense
des droits humains
constitutif de notre République d'une
certaine façon d'une certaine manière
c'est ça devrait l'aide ce n'est pas
puisqu'on l'expliquait que c'est en il
n'y a pas de droit du sol solide c'est
un aménagement du droit qui est proposé
c'est pas une remise en cause du sang
quand même l'aménagement je veux dire
toute la ménagement ces symbolique c'est
symbolique vous commencez à rogner et de
bon alors alors on va me dire encore une
fois que je n'ai qu'à aller vivre à
Mayotte pour voir comment ça se passe
mais ça c'est un argument je veux dire
bon alors évidemment mais d'une part je
peux répondre à Madame que moi je sais
ce que ça a été d'appeler les personnes
de vous dire où vous êtes tout ça c'est
pas c'est pas exceptionnel c'est pas
particulier et spécifique à Mayotte ça a
la question d'avoir à appeler les amis
notamment on peut pas s'en satisfaire
non plus
c'est que c'est pas la question d'une je
veux dire de si on a le droit pour
parler de Mayotte il faut aller vivre à
Mayotte c'était à ça que je réponds
d'accord voilà mais revenir sur la
question du droit du sol je pense que
toute cette discussion qui se fait à
partir de Mayotte à partir aussi de ce
que vous soulignez de plusieurs fois de
cette concentre lien qui est fait entre
délinquance et immigration
donne des échos politiques au sens
beaucoup plus large qui sont inquiétants
oui je pense qu'ils sont inquiétants
absolument et qui pour moi se rapproche
d'idéologie d'extrême droite
vous réagissiez aux chiffres donc été ce
donné par le ministère de l'intérieur on
est bien d'accord si rien ne change y
aurait 700 000 habitants d'ici 25 ans
vous dites ce sont pas ce sont ce sont
les chiffres du ministère quoi il y en a
d'autres c'est vrai que je vais pas vous
asséner toute la série des chiffres mais
il faut quand même raison garder en la
matière c'est à dire que nos collègues
démographes de l'Insee Mayotte font un
travail formidable et très précis et qui
bien sûr il y a eu une croissance
spectaculaire de cette de cette
population et une des transformations
sociales économiques politiques
religieuse en l'espace de 10 ans qui
sont aussi tout à fait importante mais
imaginez que la population va continuer
sa croissance qui est pour large partie
liée à la structure d'âge de qui la
moitié de la population à moins de 17
ans
elle va il faut pas imaginer cette
explosion c'est vraiment on est dans le
domaine du fantasme de même que l'idée
selon laquelle nous interrompre 4 entre
85 2017 ça c'est ça c'est à dire
alors sur justement pour poursuivre
cette idée que le transformer le droit
du sol ça permettrait de d'empêcher une
arrivée massive qui submergerait l'île
cette idée d'un appel d'air c'est
vraiment une vision qui est complètement
faussée des faits au moins pour trois
raisons d'abord parce que
les les circulations elles se font pas
au gré du vent quand c'est un peu
l'image de l'appel d'air elles se font
depuis des années parce qu'il y a des
liens économiques familiaux religieux
entre les îles ce sont des circulations
qui sont en fait structurées anciennes
régionales et il n'y a aucun déferlement
plus immédiatement cette idée
[Musique]
mais on est aussi dans une logique de
encore une fois de circulation entre les
îles de peuplement de cette qui est lié
à au circulation au sein de l'archipel
c'est à dire que
vous voyez cette image de Mayotte comme
un contenant ou viendrait
s'agglomérer tout une série de personnes
qui viennent de l'extérieur elle est
encore une fois pas du tout cohérente
par rapport à la dynamique de sa
population vous allez pouvoir dérouler
les deux autres arguments je vous le
promets mais je voudrais entendre le
sénateur là-dessus parce que cette
réforme du droit de sol est-ce que vous
y êtes favorable déjà on parle beaucoup
de droits du sol le droit du sol n'a pas
été remis à cause à Mayotte comme vous
l'avez très bien dit et j'en parle
d'autant plus que c'est moi qui ai porté
ses dispositions pour les faire voter au
Sénat puis ils ont été votés à
l'Assemblée nationale les conditions
d'accès à la nationalité lorsque l'on
est à Mayotte
sont modifiés un conformité avec la
Constitution et les conventions
internationales je suis allé défendre
ces dispositions devant le Conseil
d'État c'est le président l'archet qui
avait
transmis ma proposition de loi au
Conseil d'État donc vous dites cette
aménagement et ça ne remet pas ce que
les arguments de gérer c'était puissant
en disant que le symbole est important
aussi pour vous ça ne remet pas en cause
ce symbole ça le remet pas en cause et
en tout cas ça adapte la législation
comme le permet la constitution à la
situation de de l'île moi j'ai expliqué
au Conseil d'État que le fondements de
du droit du sol tel que nous les
connaissons dans notre pays dans la
France ont été détournés on assiste à
une fraude massive où vous avez des des
centaines et des milliers d'enfants qui
sont nés sur le territoire Mahoré des
femmes viennent exprès des des Comores
juste pour donner naissance à l'heure
enfant pour qu'ils acquièrent la
nationalité française et on oublie une
dimension c'est que les Comores le
pouvoir comorien encourage cet exode
puisque le gouvernement comorien
continue à revendiquer Mayotte donc moi
je veux bien qu'on raisonne comme si
nous étions dans n'importe quel
situation dans le monde non la situation
à Mayotte est particulière parce que les
Comores continuent à revendiquer libre
en deux au lieu de vision différente au
lieu de stopper cette émigration vers
Mayotte au contraire il encourage en
disant de toutes les façons allez-y vous
êtes chez vous alors un mot rapide
Mathieu ensuite vous redonne la parole
moi je m'interrogeais sur ce que vous
disiez sur ça fait le jeu de l'extrême
droite au fond de commencer à toucher le
droit du sol et on peut se poser quand
même la question à Mayotte de qu'est-ce
qui fait le jeu de l'extrême droite
parce que quand on regarde le score qui
a fait Marine Le Pen en 2017 le score
qu'elle a fait en 2022
c'est spectaculaire celle qu'on peut le
rappeler elle fait 24% au premier tour
et la rive derrière Emmanuel Macron en
2017 elle fait plus de 42% au premier
tour est loin devant tout le monde 60
pour 2022 et au second tour c'est
l'inverse c'était c'était
Marine Le Pen en 2017 et c'est l'inverse
en 2002 arrivait en tête avec près de
60% des voix donc qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui fait le jeu de l'extrême
droite on voit ce que c'est de laisser
cette situation perdurer ou est-ce que
ce sont les discours qui sont qui sont
entretenus et nous on a vu de se
transformer les revendications des
maorets dans les mobilisations ce qu'on
a suivi depuis une dizaine d'années
quand même et on a vu le l'exigence
d'égalité qui est liée aussi à l'idée
d'être resté française d'être devenu
département français cette exigence
d'égalité et cette lutte contre la vie
chère qui était dans toutes les dans
toutes les mobilisations se transformer
au fil des années avec l'idée que on
allait d'abord et prioritairement
résoudre cette inégalité qui n'arrive
pas cette promesse qui n'est toujours
pas tenue c'est c'est difficulté qui
sont réelles qui sont urgentes qu'on
allait les résoudre en se débarrassant
des étrangers qui sont présents sur le
sol Mahorais mais qu'appelle-t-on
étranger à Mayotte quand on sait qu'un
tiers de ces enfants sont nés à Mayotte
est-ce que ces enfants on a pu entendre
dans le débat public cette idée que on
les voyant devenir citoyen français ils
allaient éventuellement militer pour
revenir dans les Comores alors ça je
peux vous le dire depuis les enquêtes
qu'on a menées auprès d'eux ces jeunes
n'ont absolument aucune intention mais
quelle qu'elle soit de revenir de
remettre en cause maillot de français ou
de ils se sont
les jeunes ne remettent en cause c'était
quoi le le l'autre argument que je
voulais indiquer justement cette réforme
de 2018 qui exige donc cette
position de de régularité du séjour des
parents pour pouvoir accéder à la
nationalité une fois devenue adulte
sachant que c'est un parcours d'embûches
terrible parce qu'il y a des
discriminations au guichet parce qu'il y
a des grandes difficultés à faire valoir
ses droits et ça a encore une fois ça ne
concerne pas que les étrangers il y a
une difficulté d'accès aux droits tout à
fait importante et donc le durcissement
qui est je crois porter à cette exigence
de l'égalité du séjour à un an non
seulement elle va être très difficile à
faire y compris pour des gens qui
pourraient prétendre à être en ces jours
réguliers mais qui ne peuvent pas le
faire parce que encore une fois les
services publics ne leur permettent pas
de le faire mais surtout ça n'a
parfaitement rien changé à aux
circulations entre les îles qui
répondent là dessus à d'autres logiques
donc changer le droit du sol non
seulement ne va pas résoudre les
problèmes de violence
notre journaliste ça ne perd de la font
ça n'a pas changé la situation de la
circulation ça c'est à vérifier mais la
première réponse que devait apporter ces
dispositions c'était justement contenu
de cette fraude massive et dans dans un
contexte de revendications d'un pays
d'un pays étranger et bien si on n'avait
pas stoppé ce processus par ces
dispositions limitantes les conditions
d'accès à la nationalité et bien en une
décennie en deux décennies en trois
décennies nous nous serions retrouvés
avec
des personnes nées massivement sur le
territoire Mahoré et qui n'aurait pas eu
on n'aurait pas eu le temps
de d'inculquer les us et les coutumes
les traditions de l'île et
un cas de vote par exemple sur l'avenir
de Mayotte que c'est ces personnes
puissent voter à la rencontre des
intérêts qui est en danger c'est ça
j'essaie de comprendre ce que vous dites
la culture mahoraise l'identité
mahoraise effectivement elle peut être
menacée par par ce processus massif de
fraude à la nationalité française est-ce
que est-ce que est-ce que un autre
territoire
par exemple
allez-y termine votre phrase pardon à la
Réunion à la Réunion est-ce que ce
phénomène même la moitié même 10% de ce
qui se passe à Mayotte serait toléré
madame mais vous me posez la question
comme si j'allais répondre pour des
personnes qui vont tout de suite faire
le lien entre immigration et d'infect
mais quand à la Réunion il y a par
exemple aujourd'hui quand esprit donc
qui arrive et qu'il y a des réactions
totalement racistes sur je me repose à
ces réactions réunionnaises c'est pas
parce que ce sont des Réunionnais qui
sont racistes que je trouve ça mieux que
parce que parce qu'ils sont régnés
au nombre de de naissance est-ce que
vous accepteriez à la Réunion vous ou
les pouvoirs politiques à la Réunion
pour répondre pour les pouvoirs
politiques mais moi je peux vous dire
que oui pour moi la question la question
de l'immigration qui est posée comme ça
comme des personnes qui resteront
constamment étrangères et je sais pas ce
que ça ce que ça peut signifier qui ne
pourront pas devenir finalement des
personnes contribuant à la société à
Mayotte je trouve ça c'est ce sont des
projections je ne comprends pas toutes
les personnes qui sont arrivées en
France la plupart des personnes sur
Internet en France sont devenus Français
je veux dire ce centre français ils
participent
est-ce qu'il y a une spécificité de
Mayotte et est-ce que effectivement on
n'est pas un niveau tel que c'est devenu
intolérable je crois que c'est 48%
aujourd'hui si je ne me trompe de la
population qui est étrangère à Mayotte
je voyais 49% pour être précis Anne
perzo la font demandez la parole je vais
donner un autre chiffre 77% de la
population et il est très important 77%
de la population vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté à Mayotte est-ce que Mayotte a
les moyens de peu supporter cette afflux
de population on peut aussi poser la
question comme ça
oui en fait moi ce que je voudrais
simplement c'est que tout le monde
arrête des positions dogmatiques parce
que ça va pas aider l'île mais en fait
ce que je veux ce que je veux vraiment
se souhaiterais c'est que tout le monde
aide cette île que personne n'est en
arrière-plan des peut-être des sujets de
dire Mayotte pourrait être trop
comorienne ou j'en sais rien où il ne
faut pas avoir des des positions
dogmatiques ce que ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'on arrête qui est 7400 naissances
comme il y a eu en 2021 sur les 10600
naissance 7400 d'origine de mer
comorienne parce que le problème c'est
nous on veut bien ne pas faire de lien
du tout avec la délinquance mais du coup
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est que il y a
il y avait 800 enfants qui n'étaient pas
scolarisés maintenant ils sont 900
enfants qui ne sont pas scolarisés
comment on fait moi c'est ça c'est en
fait c'est comment est-ce que qui peut
proposer quelque chose
pour pour qu'on y arrive en fait ils se
sont pas scolarisés parce qu'il y a pas
assez de construction
on est sur un territoire de 374 km².
donc comment se fait la délinquance mais
elle se fait en fait parce qu'il y a une
délinquance de survie dans les ados et
chez les très jeunes mais en fait ils
sont pas scolarisés alors il y a des
solutions je veux dire il y a des gens
qui sont admirables des associations
admirables qui font des écoles à la
maison ou qui qui se débrouillent mais
c'est pas des solutions viables comment
moi j'aimerais entendre des des
propositions de solutions les Comores
ont maintenu eux ils ont le droit du
sang en France il y a le droit du sol
qui est admirable on est bien d'accord
mais comment on fait je vous pose la
question quelle solution vous proposez
Françoise verger si finalement la
politique qui est mise en place
aujourd'hui vous semble mener à une
impasse qu'est ce que qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire je pense que je vendrai à
Madame qui est connu mieux c'est qui a
fait ses études mais toutes les études
montrent que les personnes qui partent
en fait en majorité ne voudrait pas
quitter leur pays s'il le pouvait si
elle le pouvait elle ne quitterait pas
leur pays déjà donc ne coûte ne
quitterai pas ensuite les questions de
circulation de penser que Mayotte
appartient à l'archipel donc il y a bien
aussi
je veux dire de s'occuper de ça alors
quelle est la solution
vont marcher parce qu'on peut continuer
comme ça en accusant la République des
Comores d'être responsable de tout je
veux dire moi tout ça ça me semble au
contraire justement pas du tout des
solutions je veux dire ça me semble
complètement de poser la question chaque
fois mais leur qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire toutes ces femmes qui viennent
donner naissance mais je veux dire
accueillons leurs enfants je sais pas
moi je trouve ça c'est une manière
complètement alors on va me dire mais
venez à Mayotte vous verrez si vous
pourrez vivre là-bas mais c'est pas du
tout dogmatique moi la question que je
que je pose c'est que je pense pas que
cette la solution sécuritaire les
solutions de retirer le droit du sol
vont répondre on a bien vu par exemple
en France toutes les répressions contre
les réfugiés et les migrants ne mettent
pas fin au fait que des personnes
continuent à venir parce qu'elles sont
poussées par la misère par la guerre ou
par d'autres choses donc moi je veux
bien qu'on se parle comme ça en disant
que ça soit dogmatique que ce soit l'air
mais je veux dire je ne suis quand même
pas la seule je parle d'avancer
internationale
à mettre en place alors je corrobore
quand même l'idée
je trouve ça intéressant de dire
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire d'autre alors
si vous passez la fermeture des
frontières n'est pas une solution parce
que de manière factuelle et non pas
idéologique mais factuel ça ne marche
pas les gens continuent de franchir la
frontière quand bien même elle est
militarisée c'est vrai pour toutes les
frontières du monde donc il faut
chercher des solutions ailleurs et là
elles sont assez évidentes les
politiques publiques sont complètement
sousdimensionnés à Mayotte deux fois
moins de dépenses que pour d'autres
départements les politiques sociales qui
sont ce département et celui qui aurait
le département encore plus attractif
pour pour ceux qui viennent d'ailleurs
pourquoi il faut de construire les deux
parce que c'est pas au nom du fait que
ça le département serait trop attractif
que le SMIC n’est pas au même niveau que
les retraites ne sont pas au même niveau
que les prestations sociales ne sont pas
au même niveau parce qu'on leur dit non
ça va augmenter l'attractivité de
Mayotte or les migrations n'obéissent
pas assez logique jamais jamais en fait
les personnes qui traversent il y en a
plein qui ne réclament même pas leurs
droits des solutions
un faisceau de solutions qu'il faut
enclencher ensemble la lutte contre
l'immigration que clandestine il faut la
continuer cette disposition sur le le la
modification du droit
et bien elle ne elle ne produit pas tous
ses effets parce que ce qu'avait
préconisé le Conseil d'État n'est pas
appliqué c'est-à-dire faire une
publicité pour que pour que les les
femmes soient dissuadées de venir à
Mayotte et lutter contre les
reconnaissances de complaisance et ça ça
n'est pas fait c'est la fin de ce débat
merci beaucoup merci à tous peut y avoir
participé ici et en duplex depuis
Mayotte à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat
je vous dis à demain pour un nouveau
numéro de sciences publiques et votre
prochain rendez-vous politique dans la
matinale Oriane mansini reçoit le
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft ce
sera à 8h du matin belle soirée à toutes
et à tous merci